aquí tenemos una figura con cuatro lados
o sea un cuadrilátero en donde nos
marcan que este lado es paralelo a este
de acá entonces por definición esta
figura es un trapecio un trapecio
trapecio y lo que queremos hacer es
determinar el área de este trapecio
conociendo las longitudes que nos dan
por aquí bueno déjame empezar haciendo
lo siguiente vamos a multiplicar 6 por 3
6 por 3 eso que nos daría eso representa
el área de una figura aquí que sería
justo un rectángulo con base 6 y altura
3 es decir sería el área de esta figura
que ahorita voy a voy a marcar vale
entonces tendríamos este rectángulo
grande aquí afuera claramente el área
del trapecio debe ser menor que el área
de este rectángulo rojo bueno ahora qué
sucedería si hacemos dos por tres y
hacemos dos por tres
esos de nuevo sería el área de un
rectángulo que ahora sería más pequeña
que el trapecio pero déjame seguir
haciendo esto déjame continuar con el
experimento para ver qué sucede vale
entonces vamos a hacer dos por tres
y entonces ahora sería el área el área
de este rectángulo pequeño de aquí con
base 2 y altura altura 3 más o menos
algo de este estilo vale déjame marcar
esta área así en amarillo para saber
para saber qué es esto de acá vale
entonces tenemos esta área de acá ok
bueno parece ser que el área del
trapecio queda justo entre el área
amarilla y el área del rectángulo rojo y
no sería muy descabellado pensar que
quede justo a la mitad y esto se debe a
que las diferencias déjame marcar las
diferencias
las diferencias de áreas son esta de acá
esta de acá y esta de acá y de esas
diferencias el trapecio reclama justo la
mitad a qué me refiero con que reclama
justo la mitad a que observa de este
lado tenemos dos triángulos congruentes
y el trapecio agarra esta área
y esta área de aquí de este lado tenemos
dos triángulos congruentes y el trapecio
agarra uno de los triángulos que sería
este triángulo de acá y por lo tanto es
bastante razonable que el área del
trapecio que sería todo esto todo esto
que está marcado en verde quede justo a
la mitad a la mitad del área del
rectángulo amarillo y el rectángulo rojo
vale entonces para obtener el área lo
que tenemos que hacer es promediar estas
dos cantidades
promediar seis por tres más dos por tres
es decir este esto lo dividimos entre
dos vale seis por tres y dos por tres
que es lo que promedia mos bueno esta es
una forma de pensarlo pero también
podemos pensarlo de la siguiente forma
lo que voy a hacer es factorizar un 3
voy a multiplicar aquí por 3 y voy a
dividir entre 2 y aquí adentro voy a
poner 6
+ 2 más 2 sale y una tercera forma de
pensarlo es así esto también es lo mismo
que hacer 62 entre dos y luego
multiplicarlo por 3
entonces nos quedaría
más dos entre dos y luego multiplicarlo
por tres estos simplemente son varias
formas de ver un mismo resultado una
forma es simplemente promediar las dos
áreas las del rectángulo pequeño con el
rectángulo grande otra forma es
considerar este segmento y este segmento
y sumarlos luego eso multiplicarlo por
la altura y finalmente dividir entre dos
y una tercera forma de ver el área es
tomar el promedio de este lado con este
lado o sea seis más dos entre dos y
luego multiplicarlo por tres de hecho
esta tercera forma nos da otra
interpretación geométrica bonita esta de
acá se puede pensar de la siguiente
forma un segmento de longitud 6 más 2
entre 2 quedaría justo a la mitad del
trapecio justo a la mitad del trapecio
entonces lo que está haciendo esta
formulita es tomar un rectángulo un
rectángulo cuya base es justo la línea
media del trapecio la que queda justo a
la mitad
y con altura con altura 3 vale la altura
del trapecio entonces este esta tercer
fórmula nos dice que el área del
trapecio es la misma que el área de este
rectángulo de este rectángulo que estoy
pintando por acá bueno entonces tenemos
tres formas de representar exactamente
lo mismo que es el área del trapecio
ésta está ahí está vamos a calcular
cuánto nos da en este ejemplo nos
debería de dar lo mismo en las tres
verdad entonces vamos a ver cuánto es
igual esto esto es igual a saber 6 13 18
23 2 por 3 perdón 6 por 3 18 2 por 13 66
más 18 24 y 24 entre 2 es 12 a 62 es 8 8
por 3 24 y 24 entre 12 12 y a ver si acá
queda lo mismo seis más dos es 88 entre
dos es cuatro y cuatro por tres es igual
a 12 entonces el área de este trapecio
es 12 unidades cuadradas